[Music]
I worry that we're all kind of
disconnected did you ask me something
huh what this fine okay good
night Ce do you think it's good for you
to live like this head up you're really
not supposed to use your hands why
family meeting downstairs let's go can
you help me with this problem I'm
kidding you can't help me no I can't we
are going to make a happy memory as a
family I wish you could be me I would
love for you to be me for one day I
would love for you to know what it's
like to be me I would kill to eat a
dozen donuts and just have it burn right
off would you take a picture of my
family please everybody say merry
[Music]
Christmas what are you doing in my bed I
my bed why am I in your bed
[Music]
mom what is happening that's me
see Mom
why
there this is a situation that has never
happened before I'm 17 again I'm 13
Going on 30 so freaky what's wrong with
Pickles what's going on with Miles
pickles is Miles what's My Age Again we
just need to get through today and
figure out how this happened your dad
happens to be the toast and high
school's kind of my jam you stole my
first kiss no I pulled away you rejected
Ariana Dad I can't believe I thought we
could pull this off be a boss a boss be
a boss be a
boss what's My Age
Again sounds like you need to fix what
is broken we've got this for Walkers and
Walkers never quit
Crips I think I T
A more than anything I just just want
you to be okay we have 24 hours we don't
figure this out we're going to be stuck
like this forever this is the most
exciting thing I've done in years
whatever happens we'll get through it
together this is just a dream and we
have to wake up flap
[Music]
me I think the dog and the baby are
spending too much time together what's
My Age
Again